hey folks and welcome to console crew
your weekly roundup of everything
playstation xbox and nintendo
i'm lucy james and joining me as usual
i've got xbox expert jordan remain
yo and playstation pro tomorrow hello
everyone how are we today
it's good of course you're into this
meeting because no i'm just
[Laughter]
this is an intervention it's either an
intervention or you're some kind of uh
you're some kind of inspector and you're
making your final deduction
which is funny because i'm actually the
one who is putting the question
to you all and everyone at home who's
watching
because i was thinking about the year
ahead and it's a
weird one for games man it's so weird
so my question is is 2021 gonna be the
weirdest year for triple a gaming
ever
okay you could argue that 2020 was
pretty
weird but we also had like some
semblance of normality that was kind of
like
digital e3's digital gamescom
digital um game awards and in terms of
releases i think we had a pretty steady
stream of triple a's a few
a few delays here and there and then we
also had like console releases which
made at least for me made me feel like
we had some normality because everyone
was thinking about those and the
releases that came alongside them
2020 was relatively normal
however 2021 is where we're really
starting to see the effects
of what 2020 had in the world and that's
never been more evident when you look at
the releases
for the rest of the year as gamers we're
looking at
ourselves in the mirror and our
calendars and asking ourselves
what is there to live for what games
what games what games are around and
coming ways that makes it
keep it up
but no i mean you're right like i don't
know about you but i
weirdly plot out my year based on what
games i think i'm going to be playing
and
maybe it's just because you know this
has been my life and my job for so long
it's like i think of
summer oh it's e3 and then it's gamescom
and then it's this and then it's that
and then it's you know
november there'll be a card and a
battlefield and this will probably come
out here and it's just very strange to
look at the confirmed releases
and just go well beyond may nothing
really has a release date
this is my kind of year this is my kind
of year no triple a's in sight
and just indies indies as far as the eye
can see
everywhere the light touches there will
be an indie game the thing is like we'll
go through some of the games that we're
kind of got our eyes on but the indies
aren't the
kind of like they're not they're not the
exception to the
tba rule where we don't know where they
are what they're
where they're coming out there's like
we've got a whole list of indie games
that we're excited for but all of the
release dates are
to be announced yeah you know it's just
all like
2021 at some point in time yeah
it's big you know like i hate to invoke
cyberpunk when it's ready
but you know that's what that's what
everything is and you know so beyond may
up until may we've got things like
return near replicant
um resident evil village death loop
thank god mass effect
uh legendary edition which is weirdly my
most it's not weirdly but it is my most
anticipated game of the year because i'm
just
just very very excited to get back into
it and then after that you know you've
got
kana you've got halo infinite apparently
and it's the 20th anniversary of halo
and xbox so they would be
it would be bad if they skipped that but
you know david halo doesn't make it out
this year
doesn't come to a year party we're going
to be very upset
but then sorry i'm i'm getting emotional
because of all of the games that i don't
know the idea of not having david halo
this year
i've named him david too much david halo
his name is john but i've changed it to
david
that's fine there has to be a spartan
out there whose name is david
yeah david haley but no i mean you know
you got life strange two colors
um skyward sword ghostway tokyo a
question mark
god of war ragnarok a question mark
forbidden west
a question mark i feel like god of war
is a big old question mark like because
they were aiming for the end of 2021 and
i'm like i feel like that's just gonna
slide into early 2022 at this point
i mean uh god of war 2018 came out on
420 a release date that i will never
forget
um so i you know blaze it boy yeah
blazing it up or playing god of war
no so i can you know totally see them
taking that slot again it's not like it
did the money harm
but it's just you know we've got maybes
so many maybes you've got like card
rumors of battlefield i put overwatch 2
in this list because i hate myself
crossfire x diablo 2 remastered and then
you've got things like dying light 2 who
the hell knows what's happening with
that
far cry 6 which is a very very weird one
and then
like lego skywalker saga which
realistically should have come out
when the rise of skywalker came out but
i mean so let's let's take all this into
account we've kind of like looked at the
landscape for the next
uh few months and it's does it feel
weird to you guys that we don't
really have those usual tentpoles i
think i think it's
i think it's weird in that even
even the things that we know will
probably make it we're starting to
question
like there's a i i don't doubt that
there will be a call of duty
or a battlefield this year but we're
still kind of like well there though
and i think that's the kind of situation
where we're in we're in a state now
where
given the way of the world and things
that have happened
the kind of cadence of releases that
we're so used to and have been used to
over the last few years and even
generations has been kind of upended
and that is both an exciting thing and
also a kind of terrifying thing because
like you said
as people who we kind of live and die by
a release calendar
um or at least many of us as fans of the
medium kind of like
we plot how much energy to you know
store up for get hype getting hype
based on release calendars um that's
it's kind of thrown us all into a bit of
disarray
at the same time it is exciting because
you know people are rethinking the way
they approach releases and like jordan
alluded to
it's given so much breathing room to to
indies like and
i i have started like making a conscious
effort to play
indie games like i used to before aaa
games
one were so abundant two weren't games
that you played for 20 hours and
moved on from they became this is your
life now and you have to play it and
cover it and otherwise no one will
you know care about anything you say and
i feel like now i'm in a situation where
i'm
looking see i seeking out games to play
like i played
devotion the other day and it was like i
sat down i was like yes
wow i i haven't sat down to play a game
like devotion
in so long i remember loving doing this
so it is weird but i think the important
thing like
when you're scared and you're worried
that no there's no video game releases
and you're a bit turned around just
remember there's loads of
new video games out there you just need
to find them and give yourself the time
to play them
because it's good but having said that i
am i am desperate for some you know
meaty games to to get into you know i
want some i want that
cinema style experience it's one of
those weird things that
when you try to think about how like we
approach video games so differently than
the general public
approaches video games like there are
people out there who
like their entire lives probably like
revolve around oh i get the new call of
duty and the new
assassins creed and that's pretty much
all the major new games that i get
every single year and so i'm very
curious like what is
what are their plans for a year like
this where so many of their
probably usual tent poles aren't they're
like we're
building content around games like
outriders returnal
kana like games that we probably would
have covered
anyway regardless would have happened
but will people turn
to games like this that are a little bit
bigger than indies but smaller than your
traditional
aaa in a year where it's just kind of
bare of the
usual tentpole titles i honestly think
that we've sort of covered this in a
roundabout way before but when we've
been talking about game paths
i think this is gonna be the year where
people just
think okay well nothing's coming out
i've got this service i'll just dip in
and i think there's gonna be this big
resurgence of older games which is
you know really unfortunate that at the
same time you've got sony out here being
like
no old games for you bye
access denied cut off and so i
i honestly like it's not even just those
people who
you know people like us who actively
look forward to the all the next huge
big releases and you know like keep up
to date with everything
i don't know what's gonna happen to the
people who like you say just get the big
annualized
franchises but then there's also this
big looming question about how
development is gonna go forward um after
this because obviously what
everyone's still feeling the effects of
the quarantines the shutdowns
um but not even that you know you've got
part shortages
um production issues and then
it's like what is life going to be like
in hopefully a covert free
world you know are developers going to
be going back into the studio
and being able to create things the way
they used to which is
probably you know obviously there's been
an adjustment period as everyone's got
used to working from home
but also are people going to want to do
that anymore studio is going to want to
you know pay for all that real estate if
you know
now that the kinks have been worked
through everyone could just do it from
home and so it's
2021 is this weird year where everyone's
like
semi trying to get back to the way
things were before but also have to
realize that it's an entirely new world
yeah and
yeah the you know people have made big
life decisions based on
the things that have happened the last
year where you're living in a city where
it's expensive and
that city you might have moved to
because it's a
it's a hub for video game development
right like it's there's certain cities
in the world san francisco being one of
them like
various cities in canada and parts of
london as well where people go there
because they know there's a
a concentration of jobs for game
development
but then in a pandemic where everyone's
working from home
you're like well i don't need to be here
i can make the game that i'm working on
from somewhere else and like the idea of
now being like everything's back come
and
move back to this expensive city where
you've shown that you can
still do your job outside of being here
and that's going to be interesting
that's going to be tricky and
i feel like this is people might be
watching this thinking about why why is
this important to the
the games but like the the reason it's
important is because this is
has a very high chance of forever
changing the way that games are made
and and that has a knock-on impact on
how releases work because
people are going to want to take more
time when they're working or from home
and you know not immediately
concentrated in one studio and that
means that
you know maybe development cycles become
a little more protracted but then you
have to think about what's the
pushback from publishers who have these
kind of like tentpole release dates
staked in the ground and build their
kind of stock and their entire marketing
cycles around it and
it's going to be interesting and it's
really fascinating to see how it unfolds
but yeah in in the short term it's just
going to be
a bit confusing for a lot of people well
as well you don't know
i mean god knows what's going to happen
this year there are rumors of
online e3s people talking about what's
gonna happen with gamescom
pax uh pax east has been cancelled but
the rest of them are still on
for like the end of the year
yeah if you if you are if you are
involved in scheduling comic con i tamar
hussein not
not as a representative gamespot just me
would like you to
we're probably gonna have to we're gonna
have to cut that
just
and thank you for your time yeah but
so i don't know about you but i can't
see myself going back to
a gamescom convention hall this year i
don't
i genuinely don't think my nerves could
handle being around that many people
after spending
over a year and shut down um seeing only
like three people
um but you know those are the big ten
poll events that developers would have
to work towards you know you'd have a
build that you could show off at e3 that
people could play on the show floor at
pax
and so you know you can't underestimate
what losing those is gonna be like you
know
how many people go to gamescom like four
hundred thousand
two too many ridiculous like that and so
you know based on the pictures it looks
like way too many people go
dick games come every year it's too many
and so
it's gonna it's gonna be very strange
because well like
you'll if if you don't have those events
you are then
vying for space at like a playstation
digital event or an xbox digital event
or a nintendo one
and it's like that's not the same as
someone going hands-on with your game
for 15 minutes
compar you know compared to oh here's a
minute long trailer
packed in alongside a bunch of other
minute long trailers
so it's gonna be a weird one and that's
why i think 2021 like all of those
points that we just talked about is just
such a strange
year i i mean i know everyone's thinking
like oh we're through 2020 the vaccine's
on the way stuff's opening up
things are going to go back to normal i
just really don't think that's going to
happen i think our lives have been
completely changed yeah like just in the
same way that the industry is going to
be like
irrevocable irrevocably changed you see
i was thinking of that word and i was
like i'm just not going to try and say
it
changed like uh i think human
interaction has to be
factored into that like like you said
like
where sometimes i see people out in the
road and i wonder if i could ever like
shake their hand again and chances are
probably not
like i'm like yeah but like even based
on that like there's so
much that like the general public
doesn't really
see at something like gdc or e3 that
goes into advertising a game like
there's so many times that like a
developer will
pull someone aside like or a publisher a
journalist and be like hey there's this
thing that we're working on that we
can't really talk about yet
like and so we're just going to talk to
you kind of
face to face so that there's no paper
trail there's
the fact that like there are so many
games that i would not have been
interested at all just watching the
trailer but actually getting hands on
with it
i was like oh this game is yeah yeah the
word of mouth stuff too it's like you
know
oh you have to go go now there's this
thing on the show floor
it's right at the back no one else is
really talking about it but it's
my game of the show and you know you're
gonna have those moments
so all that being said what are the
things that you are looking forward to
in 2021 jordan i'll come to you
first well in a perfect world they would
have confirmed that hollow knight silk
song is already coming out this year and
i would say that
i should have expected but because
apparently team cherry hates me
specifically
uh yeah they've told me uh they've told
me that as long as you keep talking
about hollow knight silk song they're
just not gonna do it
that explains a lot that explains so
much probably chris tales which is
tentatively scheduled for july it's that
uh
rpg where the main character can see the
past the present and the future like all
at the same time it has this like really
awesome style turn based combat
everything that i just
love about rpgs and i
i want to play that game so badly it's
been delayed i want to say two or three
times now and they've finally been like
okay
july 2021 this is it i'm like okay
please don't delay i have nothing i have
nothing coming out like right now in
summer please give me something to do
once i'm done with mass effect for the
third time
time what about you oh
elden ring where are you i like how
we've led this first with the game
like this is what we wish that we could
be excited for in 2021 oh yeah i was
just thinking it like because i was like
oh okay elden rings not probably not
gonna make it
thankfully i have gotham knights and
then gotham knights got delays and i was
like
why why do you hate me but i think the
game i'm probably most excited about
is gonna be um like a mass effect
legendary edition is it's going to be a
big one but
also death loop is out there as well
those are the two that i'm kind of like
oh hell yeah those those those are
enough for me to stick around
oh yeah i think i think for me
definitely deathly for mass effect but
honestly i'm very excited for
12 minutes as well i think that just
looks super super cool
and honestly i'm kind of enjoying just
seeing things pop up that i have missed
so
what's that game on switch uh grim
noir oh yeah the noir game that's
genesis noir
genesis genus is what people are talking
about a lot so i've downloaded that
um and just yeah things that are things
that are popping up i'm
i'm kind of enjoying going game to game
like that but
yeah of course as everyone is probably
very very eager to play as well gran
turismo 7.
that's 2022 mate you hate to see it got
delayed
and with that let us know what you're
looking forward to in 2021
and beyond and you know let's just keep
fingers crossed that god of war doesn't
slip
i really hope to play that this year
like it's going to happen
it's not absolutely going to sleep
there's no way it comes out this year
if god of war comes out this year i will
kiss cory barlog on the mouth
i hope you both vaccinated at that point
anyway
thanks for watching we'll see you next
[Music]
week
[Music]
you